in a close presidential race or penis
measuring contest every inch counts
which is why team Trump has been using
some creative measuring in September
Donald's doctors listed him as 63 when
he'd been previously six - we'd say it
was a simple mistake but come on Trump's
doctors a medical professional was it
Mickey Rourke and castaway I want to
give you a hundred points with that I've
been calling him spammy Hagar now
Trump's BP the ghost of mayonnaise past
seems to be following suit presidential
debate it was clear that Tim Kaine
Hillary's VP and also the dad on every
Disney Channel show was substantially
taller than Mike Pence and yet when we
looked it up online
Pence's listed it taller than King what
they either chump and pence are lying or
maybe they just measure their Heights
while standing on the backs of the poor
but it's actually continue now the
business the thing what other physical
attribute might the candidates lie about
to see more presidential Bob Saget Mike
Pence a lot of people don't know this
Mike Pence can make a cucumber disappear
actually just by sitting on it okay Rich
Eisen Pence's hair is actually that
light and not the result of seeing the
ghost that haunts Trump's toupee all
right points mister proof they're too
old entitled white guys they don't have
to lie about anything